hey little guys my name is the chana and
welcome back to my safe life life series
today just coming at you with a quick
video and we're going to talk about what
static means in C++ so the static
keyword in C++ actually has two meanings
depending on what the context is one of
those applies to when you use the static
keyword outside of a class or a struct
and the other is when you use static
inside a class or struct basically just
to cut to the chase static outside of
class means that the linkage of that
symbol that you declare to be static is
going to be internal meaning it's only
going to be visible to that translation
unit that you've defined it in
whereas a static variable inside a class
or struts means that that variable is
actually going to share memory with all
of the instances of the class meaning
that basically across all instances that
you create of that class or striped
there's only going to be one instance of
that static variable and a similar thing
applies to static methods in a class
there is no instance of that class being
passed into that method we're going to
talk a lot more in depth about what
static actually means in a cloth or
struct scope so definitely check out
that video it'll be a card on the screen
and a link in the description below but
today we're just going to focus on what
static means outside of that class or
strata scope let's dive into some code
and take a look so what I'm going to do
here in this completely empty Cibola
file is just define a variable to be
static I'm going to use the s underscore
convention here to basically indicate
that this variable is static and I want
to just set it equal to five okay cool
so it looks like any other variable but
it's got the static keyword in front of
it what does that actually mean what it
means is that this variable is only
going to be linked internally inside
this translation unit if you don't know
how people slot compilation or linking
works definitely check out my videos on
how the pepperbox compiler works and how
the people go linker works because you
really need to understand what's going
on there to understand that a static
variable or function means that when it
actually comes time to link those actual
functions or variables to actually
define symbol the linker is not going to
look outside of the scope of this
translation unit for that symbol
definition yeah again this is one of
those things that's best explained by
examples let's take a look we've clearly
created a variable here and set it equal
to five what's going to another C++ file
into another translation unit yeah I've
just got a blank step upload file with a
main function we're going to create a
global variable here I'm going to give
it
exact same name as the static one I'll
set this equal to like ten or something
like that if I try and print this
variable you can see that we can compile
our code and we're not going to get any
problems and if I run my code of course
we'll get ten printing out to the
console however if I go back to my
static dot CPP file and I remove the
static keyword and I try and compile my
code you'll see that when it gets to the
linking stage we actually get a linking
error because this s variable has
already been defined in each different
translation unit so we can't have two
global variables with the same name one
of the things I could do to fix this is
change this variable to actually refer
to this one and the way that I can do
that is by getting rid of the assignment
here and marking this variable as extern
which means that it's going to look for
that s variable in an external
translation unit which is called
external linkage or external linking if
I run my code now you can see the value
we get is five because of course it's
referencing this s variable however if I
come over here and I'm Marcos of static
it's kind of like declaring a variable
private in a class no other translation
unit is going to see this s variable the
linker will not see this in a global
scope which means that if I go back here
and I try and compile my code you can
see that we actually get an unresolved
external sample F variable because it
cannot find an integer with the name F
variable anywhere because we've
effectively marked our variable as
private if we go back here I'm also
going to declare a function to show you
guys that it does the same thing if I
declare a function here called function
and another function over here which has
the same signature is also going to
return nothing is going to be void if I
try and compile this now I'm going to
get a duplicate symbol error at the
linking stage because there are two
functions if I go over here into static
and I mark this one as static then of
course when the linker stuff to link all
this it's not going to see the static
one and thus I'm not going to get any
errors let's try and compile this you
can see I don't get the error anymore
for the function I still get the F
variable one let's just get rid of that
and be print as well if I compile this
we get no errors out so that's really
all the static means when you use it
outside of a class or a struct in C++ it
just means that when you declare that
static function or that static variable
is only going to be visible to that
tablecloth file that you've declared it
in
if you want to declare a static variable
in a header file and include that header
file in two different C++ files and
effectively what you've done is what
I've kind of done with my example where
I've had that same s variable declared
as a static variable in both translation
units because of course when you include
that header file it's going to copy all
the contents and paste it into that
develo file so what you've done is you
just created a static variable in two
different translation units as to why
you would use this think about why you
would use private in a class kind of
environment you basically want to use
static as much as you can if you don't
need the variable to be global because
as soon as you start declaring things in
a global scope without that static
keyword you can see that the link is
going to pick it up across translation
units which means that you've created a
variable that is completely global if I
create a variable with the name variable
and it's in a global setting suddenly
that that name variable is completely
global and can be used anywhere and that
can lead to some pretty bad bugs and
that comes down to the whole thing that
global variables are bad which I don't
particularly agree with I'll probably
make a video about that in the future
but the point is try and mark your
functions and your variable static
unless you actually need them to be
linked across translation Mina as I
mentioned earlier in the video if you
want to know more about this in a class
first drop setting click on the screen
you'll be taken to that video but I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button let me know
what you think in the comments below if
you want any kind of clarification you
also follow me on Twitter and Instagram
links will be in the description below
if you really like this video and you
want to see a lot more of them you can
support me on patreon the converse - the
channel if you do that you'll also
receive early draft of upcoming videos
as well as a nice kind of group
discussion where you can talk about what
actually goes into these videos and
request topics and all of that fun stuff
man I will now to focus the whole time
with mine great but anyway I'll see you
guys later
good bye
[Music]
[Music]